everybody here is their [ __ ]  collective pants because the ground is  shifting everything that our  grandparents and parents grew up with  everything that we knew tried and true  the stable pillars of media commerce  influence persuasion the way we make  decisions the things we buy and how what  is cool and what is not is on [ __ ]  call there's instability in the  foundation of how it was which makes an  innovator like me  [ __ ] happy let me be very clear with  this ending rant that game is over and  the people that are going to win over  the next five to seven years  are going to be very comfortable in  controlled [ __ ] chaos so you better  get your speed up you better work harder  you better work smarter you better try  things you better keep your  subjectiveness and your ego at the door  because that slows you down and it  doesn't make you do